En este video vamos a hablar sobre
la electroscopía, que tiene que ver
con las interacciones entre la luz y la
materia. Y cuando hablamos de la luz no
sólo hablamos de luz visible, estamos hablando de
radiación electromagnética en general. Y bueno,
lo que vamos a hacer en este video es obtener
una intuición por aquí utilizando el simulador
Phet de la Universidad de Colorado. Así que te
invito que vayas a este sitio web y lo intentes
por tu cuenta. Y podemos darnos cuenta de que
esencialmente el simulador nos permite ver cómo
diferentes longitudes de ondas de radiación
electromagnética pueden interactuar con la
materia, en este caso varias moléculas. Y
sólo para orientarnos podemos hacer clic
en este botón de Mostrar espectro de luz. Bien,
y podemos ver en este diagrama lo que la gente
normalmente considera ondas de radio. Estas
son algunas de las frecuencias más bajas y
de las longitudes de onda de luz más largas. Y
después, cuando vamos a frecuencias más altas,
pasamos a las microondas. Y, ojo, tener una
frecuencia más alta implica tener una energía más
alta por fotón. Después, si tenemos una frecuencia
y una energía más alta, llegamos al infrarrojo;
y después, si aumentamos la frecuencia y
la energía, llegaremos a la luz visible,
ésta es la que pueden percibir nuestros ojos; y
luego, si aumentamos la frecuencia y la energía un
poco más, llegamos a la luz ultravioleta, después
a los rayos X y después a los rayos Gamma. Ojo,
esta no es una escala lineal, es una escala
logarítmica; estas son potencias de 10. Podemos
ver algunos incrementos muy drásticos en la
frecuencia y en la energía conforme vamos
de izquierda a derecha. Pero en este video nos
enfocaremos en particular en las longitudes de
ondas electromagnéticas de microondas, infrarrojo,
luz visible y ultravioleta, y pensaremos en cómo
interactúan con distintas moléculas. Entonces,
si empezamos con la radiación de microondas,
y por acá seleccionamos una molécula de agua,
y echamos a andar la simulación, podemos ver
que cuando se absorbe la radiación provoca una
transición de rotación en la molécula de agua,
hace que la molécula de agua gire de una
manera distinta a como lo hacía antes; y
luego la molécula de agua también puede emitir la
radiación y luego rotar de manera diferente. Así
que podemos ver que no siempre hace esto, hay un
poco de probabilidad involucrada, pero esta es en
realidad la base de cómo funcionan las microondas.
Tu horno de microondas hace que las moléculas
de agua se agiten de manera rotatoria, lo que
aumenta el calor en el sistema. Por otra parte,
también podemos ver la luz infrarroja, que una
vez más tenemos que recordar: tiene una frecuencia
más alta, así que veamos qué le hace a las
moléculas. Así que con base en esta simulación,
parece que la molécula de agua empieza a vibrar
cuando absorbe la luz infrarroja. La radiación de
microondas hizo que girara o tuviera un cambio en
el estado de rotación, mientras que el infrarrojo
la hace vibrar. Y podemos ver esto con otras
moléculas. Probemos con el monóxido de carbono.
Una vez más no la hace girar, la hace vibrar.
Ahora, ¿qué pasará con la luz visible? Bueno,
la luz visible tiene diferentes interacciones
con distintos tipos de moléculas, así que
intentemos con el dióxido de nitrógeno. En ciertas
situaciones, el dióxido de nitrógeno absorberá la
luz, es por eso que brilla, y cuando brilla lo
que realmente pasa es que pone electrones en un
estado de mayor energía o en un orbital más alto,
y luego, cuando deja de brillar, los electrones
regresan a un estado de menor energía, están
reemitiendo radiación. Lo podemos ver aquí, que
justo está reemitiendo luz visible, en este caso
en una dirección distinta. Y cuando ocurre esto,
el electrón que estaba en un estado excitado
regresa a un estado de menor energía. Bien,
ahora pensemos en la luz ultravioleta, la cual
tiene una energía aún mayor que la luz visible.
¿Qué esperaremos ver? Bueno, por aquí podemos
ver que en ciertos casos toma electrones y es
capaz de excitarlos tanto que rompe su enlace
con la molécula. Vamos a reiniciarlo, es decir,
realmente podemos romper los enlaces. Veamos qué
sucede con algo de ozono. Lo mismo: excita tanto
el electrón que puede romper el enlace. Entonces
el panorama general, o la gran conclusión,
es la siguiente: la radiación de microondas
tiende a cambiar el movimiento de rotación de
una molécula, vimos eso con las moléculas de agua;
la radiación infrarroja, que es de mayor energía
y mayor frecuencia, tiende a provocar un cambio
en el movimiento vibratorio; mientras que la luz
visible puede excitar electrones de tal forma que
los lleva a un estado de mayor energía, luego son
readmitidos cuando el electrón regresa a su estado
base; por último, la luz ultravioleta es tan
poderosa que puede excitar electrones de modo que
en algunos casos puede romper enlaces covalentes.